horrific move Iran's Parliament voter
votes to execute
fifteen thousand protesters let me say
that one more time folks execute as in
Kill fifteen thousand protesters to
teach hard lesson Iranian lawmakers in
recent days call for strict punishment
for the protesters who have been
arrested on Monday CNN reported that a
letter signed by 227 members of Iranian
Parliament this is not 20. this is not
40. this is 227 Iranian Parliament urged
that the protesters be given harsh
punishment that would serve as a good
lesson in the shortest possible time on
Tuesday Parliament did just that voting
to impose the death penalty
on all protesters in custody as a hard
lesson for all Rebels the majority in
favor of the penalty was considerable
227 folks out of 290 total members
matching the number of lawmakers who
signed the letter a court in Iran has
issued the first death sentence to a
person arrested for taking part of the
protests that have engulfed the
country's State media state state media
says keep this in mind it's 220 out of
290 okay this this is this is not
minority that's saying this we're like
oh my God they're so extremists no no
this is Iran's Parliament extremists 227
victory over 63 to have 15 000
protesters be executed so here's my my
concern that's my concern
um
human rights typically will be something
where you know Jimmy Carters have always
been known as the human rights person oh
he ran on human rights hey I'm a human
rights activist I'm a human rights
activist this is why I'm for zelinski
this is why I'm for zelinski zelinski is
the same person that came out and
tweeted out in no time after the Poland
story came out and I don't know if you
guys saw this uh how opportunistic he
started to lose more and more
credibility by the way of course as he's
doing this he put it out and had a call
with President Expo Express condolences
president of Poland exposed condolences
over the death of Polish citizens from
Russian missile Terror we exchange
available information or clarifying all
the facts all of Europe and world must
be fully protected from terrorists
Russia so let me get this straight had a
call with President of Poland Express
condolences over the death of Polish
citizens from Russian missile Terror so
he's already saying accused accused then
he says we exchange available
information and are clarifying all the
facts wait a minute that's in what do
you call that an oxymoron like that's
like a complete opposite of
contradictory contradictory so you're
saying this and then Biden comes out hey
we need another 37 billion dollars in
Ukraine and then Iran just announced
that they want to execute 15 000 people
what is U.S gonna do about that if
you're so concerned about human rights
this is an execution this is not a bomb
this is not dying because of War this is
not soldiers done because they're on
front lines this is protesters and
during covet if we have to choose
between the left and the right that
protests did the left was way more about
protests than riots than to write the
only time the right was protesting is
the January 6th which turned into an
Insurrection be categorize it but all
the other protesting and the rights that
happened in the streets with business
owners nah it's just protesting is a
part of life in America no problem these
are peaceful protesters and now the
government saying 15 000 people are
going to get executed that's a
government
a massacre they're gonna I'd like to
know if in modern times anyone's ever
announced something like this from a
country that we have business dealings
with that we're thinking about giving
150 billion dollars to to have a nuclear
deal and saying well let's say listen
they're they're okay people in the
government but they're going to execute
15 000 protesters okay here's my
question Pat and you nailed it where the
hell is where's all the countries where
where are we to help these people
Ukraine like by the way that was to me a
setup BS thing where they just they just
saw one Missile hit two people died God
Rest their souls but they took that
opportunity to go up and then the next
day we're about to send them 40 more
billion dollars I don't think people
grasp like think about this these people
are locked up right now probably getting
tortured 15 000 people that were just in
the street saying hey the government you
know you know we're oppressed or
whatever they're going to kill them hang
them or shoot them I don't know how it's
gonna happen where the hell is everybody
where are all these people I don't I
don't give a [ __ ] and I'm tired of
hearing well Kim Kardashian tweeted the
girl that was here that day Pat remember
she would have noted whatever she's like
well Kim tweeted I don't give a [ __ ]
about a tweet where the hell is the
force where's the military action where
is the people going in there going bro
that has to be stopped are we are we
gonna just let that happen 15
000 and a couple more you're not gonna
be younger people too Pat there's kids
that were protesting they're all gonna
get murdered dude and nor are we
nobody's gonna what's the Tweet gonna do
not a goddamn thing this needs to be a
global repudiation of this this is this
is disgusting I mean we're talking about
protests I mean you went on a rant here
about what we're able to do here in
America that that went pretty viral but
this is just a message as like as as bad
as you may think you have it yeah as bad
as you may think you have it living in
the in the first world Western democracy
as victim mentality as you would like
these people just wanted to protest
basic freedoms not wearing a hijab and
they're facing the death penalty not
even facing they're getting it
overwhelmingly the the parliamentary
system in Iran voted for this what I'd
be interested in knowing that there's
probably no polling for this what is the
public sentiment like as the public you
know in in favor of this in Iran or they
all disgusted but they don't want to
raise their voices for fear of being
killed I think this is I think this is
what happens in a totalient totalitarian
theocracy where you know God wanted this
God wants these people dead for going
against the system and the government
it's just so disgusting it's crazy that
you say that just this morning because
on Instagram or just on that same post
people are like what are you talking
about America there's no way I go name
one thing that I said that isn't true
you could do whatever the hell you want
whatever you want these poor people just
stood in the goddamn Street and bro
they're sitting in there right now and
now they know their fate and nobody's
gonna do [ __ ] words to you nobody's
gonna do [ __ ] because there's no money
involved the worst thing that happens
here in America is they take away your
Twitter account okay yeah I'm sorry
you've got three YouTubers yeah Facebook
jails go to a protest here in Iran you
lose your life now this is the beauty of
America like I'm reading the story and
like part of me is like this gotta be a
goddamn onion head like that this has to
be an absurd joke no this is the reality
of living in Iran yeah and this is the
reason that our leader our CEO pbd was
forced to escape his home country thank
God you know born in Iran made in
America but just a mat you know Pat one
of the things that you the reason you do
valuetainment is so you have a voice
right I mean you would not have a voice
in Iran you wouldn't be able to speak
what's on your mind you won't be able to
start a media company the the number one
thing that I think that you the reason
you do this we've all we've alluded to
this you could retire and sit on your
money and just be chilling at this point
but you do this because you have a voice
in your necessary voice and people need
to hear what you have to say because you
come from a country like this right you
know you know what's crazy with this so
let's let's actually play this out let's
play it out
so let's play it out that they do
what they just voted for
and they execute 15 000 people let's
let's play that out God forbid that
happens
what do the Iranian people do does that
make
the revolution a hundred times stronger
or does that get people to say oh man
don't say anything because something's
gonna happen what do you think happens
if they execute fifteen thousand I have
my own opinion what do you think happens
I think Pat because of the fear of
because mind you like I said this isn't
20 this isn't 40 this isn't 50 people 15
000 people are going to get executed I
think it's gonna it's gonna call it well
I hope what I hope people more people go
on the street like in Brazil you see
they're yo in Brazil there's three
million people in the street yesterday
protesting because of the the rigged
election there I think it's gonna make
them not they're gonna they're gonna
calm down
what do you think I think I disagree I
think what happens is you usually
trigger this Noble reaction that says
I'm not giving up and now I know and I
thought I had nothing to lose now I know
I have nothing to lose because I'm not
going to live 85 years and look up one
day and say why didn't I do something
they just that's 15 000 just died for me
I am not giving up you attend to
Galvanize what's gone on take a look and
by the way this is just because we see
things this is such a dramatic statement
by a government and pbd you were asking
I haven't seen dramatic statements like
this but take a look at Darfur right
what's been going on in Darfur more than
15 000 people have died in Darfur and
you take a look at what's going on in
Syria I think over the last 10 years
more than 15 000 people died in Syria
but it hasn't been this dramatic
headline that says you 15 000 that are
in my cages right now I am done with you
and I'm doing it right now
um the West tends to watch things I mean
this goes back to the Tutsi and the Hutu
if you know you're if you know your
African history and how groups have
exterminated each other
on political or racial lines and I've
just never seen a government in the
modern time say the 15 000 that I have
in prison they're done right now you've
seen Syria you've seen Darfur that over
time rebels over here they 100 of them
die 150 of them die the numbers add up
I've just never seen it like this and I
think what that's about to happen if
they move on this they're going to
Galvanize this revolution we got two
minutes left I'll say I'll say one thing
30 seconds uh what do you think
Thanksgiving is um is coming up and you
know ever we're all going to be sitting
at the dinner table having conversations
with our family and then we joke oh
don't talk politics at the dinner table
to answer your question I want to know
what those dinner table conversations
are going to be for these 15 000
people's families having this
conversation and then their friends and
family saying did you hear about so and
so obviously you know about so-and-so
and what happens at this dinner table
will reflect upon what happens in the
country if there's people saying this is
unacceptable and there's fighting and
there's crying but if there are people
saying hey you know we can't do this I
don't think there'll be those types of
conversations but there'll always be
government support and you know in any
uh theocracy like this but those dinner
table conversations are going to be very
telling of what's going to happen moving
forward those 15 000 people how many
people think they're connected that's
all I'm just gonna say that million plus
people so how many people love those 15
000 people right what do you want to do
10 times 50 you want to do 50 times two
sisters cousins mothers everything let's
say a million people are tied to those
at least let's just say right if a
million are tight uh if if I all of a
sudden think my life is no longer worth
it and at any point this can happen to
me you're going to see a different side
of you there's something weird happens
when your life is like like this you can
lose it you you
fight in a different way you your spirit
enlar you know your spirit completely
changes when at any point this can
happen too so I don't know I I uh I I I
God forbid this happens I I pray for
this not to happen because this is a
tragic event but if Iran follows through
with this
I think it's going to be Mayhem uh to
what's going to happen to them people
that are going to show up from places
they've never ever seen before people
who were not involved are going to get
involved at levels they never seen
before it is not going to be a pretty
thing for them to do people like this
don't make it it's going to be
catastrophic for Iran's government if
they even think about doing this year
it's not going to be pretty order your
future looks bright hat click over here
and to watch the entire podcast click
here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]